[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, good afternoon.
Today at Google, we're delighted
to welcome Mr. Grant Faulkner.
Mr. Faulkner is an American
writer, the executive director
of National Novel Writing
Month, and the co-founder
of the online literary
journal "100 Word Story".
Joining him on stage is Anthony
Francis, Google's very own,
who works on the brain
robotics team at Google.
They will be discussing on
stage Mr. Faulkner's new book,
"Pep Talks for Writers--
52 Insights and Actions to
Boost Your Creative Mojo".
Please join me in welcoming
to Google Mr. Grant Faulkner.
GRANT FAULKNER: Thanks, David.
Thanks so much, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
It's great to see you.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Well,
welcome to Google.
I was wondering if you could
tell us a little bit more
about yourself, what
you write, and how
you got involved with NaNo.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
Maybe I'll back up--
I'm going to ask,
how many people
here have done National
Novel Writing Month?
OK.
I've got three
people, four people.
I am very curious if
anyone has done it
more times than Anthony has.
He's nearing a
million words right
now for his whole
NaNoWriMo career.
He started in 2002.
Has anyone done it that long?
OK.
Me included.
But I want to tell you--
maybe just for those of you
who don't know what National
Novel Writing Month is,
I'll just describe
it to you, and I
want Anthony to also give
his take on what it is,
because everyone has a different
sort of entry point to it.
It was founded in
1999 by this guy
named Chris Baty in Berkeley.
And Chris basically-- it might
not have been this suddenly--
but he woke up one morning
and kind of literally decided,
I want to write a novel.
I mean, he was an active
reader, a lover of language,
but he hadn't read any,
like, how to write books.
He hadn't taken any
writing workshops.
He just wanted to write a novel,
and he figured the best way
to do it was to write.
And that's what I
always tell people.
If you want to learn
to write a novel,
the best way is to actually
sit down and write one.
It's just such a big, crazy
experience that you have
to experience it first hand.
But anyway, Chris-- so he
looked at his bookshelves,
and he picked up some of
the more slender volumes,
so think of something about the
size of "Catcher in the Rye",
and he did a rough estimate.
And they came up with 50,000
words, was a kind of like--
the lowest edge of a
novel, lowest word count.
And he did some very
sophisticated math,
and figured out that you
could write a novel in a month
if you wrote 1,677 words a day--
I'll round up to 1,700.
And Chris recruited about 20 of
his friends to write with him.
And they met in coffee
shops after work
and they would do these
interesting challenges.
They would, for instance,
challenge each other
through word sprints, which
we still do during NaNoWriMo,
and the person who would
write the most words
would get a prize.
So they'd write for like five
minutes, and the person who
one might get a latte.
And then-- very Pavlovian
in its roots, NaNoWriMo.
And then they'd do this other
kind of Pavlovian technique
that you can't go
to the bathroom
until you've written
a thousand words.
And after the latte and
after other beverages,
this is the single
best writing--
motivational technique
in the world.
So if you're ever behind and on
deadline, drink a lot of coffee
and then don't let
yourself go to the bathroom
until you've written
a thousand words.
But anyway, the reason I
tell this story is one,
I think a lot of
people don't realize
their creative potential, or
pursue their creative dreams
because they put obstacles
in front of themselves.
And so one way that Chris
did this was like, he said,
I don't have to take
a writing workshop
to learn to write a novel.
I can just do it.
And meeting in cafes with
his friends also built in--
we're essentially, this is what
NaNoWriMo is, it's a community.
It's one part event,
one part community.
And the community part
is really important,
because they held each
other accountable.
So if someone didn't show
up for-- now we call them
write-ins--
somebody might give a
call the next day and say,
are you still working
on your novel?
Are you still making progress?
And so the whole
premise of it is,
is that you don't have to
have an MFA to be a writer.
You're a writer by writing.
That's the definition.
And that-- also we say that
everyone has a story to tell.
And this is actually
true, or true enough.
I read a survey in "The
New York Times" recently,
81% of Americans say they
want to write a book someday,
but most of them don't do it.
And that's why we exist.
We say, if you're going
to write a book someday,
those things that you say
you're going to do someday,
they rarely happen.
Have you ever noticed that?
Usually we're waiting for that
kind of perfect expanse of time
and the perfect place
to do it, but perfect--
perfection-- it never arrives.
So that's part of the
premise of NaNoWriMo
is like, make your creative
dreams happen today,
and write 50,000
words in November.
And we've expanded our
program since then.
We have a camp NaNoWriMo program
that happens in April and July,
it's a more casual
version of NaNoWriMo.
We have I Wrote A Novel, Now
What? in January and February
where we focus on
revision and publishing.
And then we have
this huge program
called the Young
Writers program,
where 80,000 kids and teens
sign up to write a novel.
When I was going to high
school, kids didn't even
think about writing a novel.
It was like something
that adults did.
So I'm really proud
of that program.
Yeah.
And Anthony has
done it since 2002.
How would you
describe NaNoWriMo?
ANTHONY FRANCIS: So it's
really interesting the stuff
that you listed, because
I've been writing
on and off for over 30 years.
And with exception
of a short story,
I'd never gotten
things published.
And I had read all the writing
books that I could find,
I took off a summer to
finish a novel once.
I tried to prioritize
my writing.
I went to 80% time at
the company I was at
to try to give myself
more time for writing,
and then they started
eating into that,
and so I switched
companies to another place
where I could do that.
I went to a writing
workshop at Dragon Con.
And none of these
things really helped
me get what I wanted,
because they were focusing
on things like creating--
improving my technique, or
creating space in my life.
They weren't focusing
on the right problem,
which was writing.
Actually focusing
on the writing.
And at that writing workshop,
I heard about National Novel
Writing Month.
And I tried it.
And I got 50,000 words into
a novel, and I was overjoyed.
And I had the intent
of following up on it,
and some stuff
happened in my life.
So that didn't happen.
But a few years later, I met
another community of writers
that were focused on writing.
It was a writing group,
but not a critique group.
It was like, we get together,
we write, we read what we wrote,
but nobody critiques.
This is just to hear the words.
And they were involved in
NaNo, and that brought me back
into it.
And that really had a
spark, because instead
of focusing on technique,
instead of focusing on how do I
create space, I'm
sitting here going,
people that have
day jobs did not
take off a month to succeed
at NaNo, they just did it.
And that broke my mindset
that I had to create space
or I had to perfect
my technique,
and some of my very best
writing has come out
of this, because you
think through your plot,
you know that you've
got your magical tattoo
artist in the second
NaNo I had, she's
about to go to a Werehouse--
W-E-R-E, house of werewolves--
and I suddenly realized, well,
I've written this into my plot,
and I have no idea what
actually happens there.
I know what happens next,
but not what happens there.
And I had to step off into
space or miss my word count.
And I ended up writing a whole
scene I never anticipated,
and characters that pushed
their way into the book
and refused to
leave, and now I'm
writing a young adult series
about this spin-off character
that came entirely through
the door opened by my NaNo.
But another part
is that community.
And even if you're just
going onto the website,
or talking with friends about
NaNo, that's really important.
I have done-- attempted NaNo--
20 times, counting NaNo,
Script Frenzy, and Camp NaNo.
I have failed twice.
And my failures
were when I decided,
oh, I'm just going
to do NaNo in a month
by myself without the support
of the whole community.
And 10,000 words
in, it just died.
Because I didn't have
that fear that I'm not
going to be able
to submit my word
count at the end of
the month, and I'm not
going to get that little
Viking hat graphic.
GRANT FAULKNER: It's very--
you want to get the
Viking hat graphic.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: I still--
GRANT FAULKNER: That's what
most people are working for.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: I have an
actual Viking hat somewhere
in my house when you
were still giving--
I don't know if you
still do or not.
But--
GRANT FAULKNER: We do.
We'll get you more Viking hats.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: I don't
need any more Viking hats.
I don't have any
place to store them.
But it's really-- it's been the
community is just as important.
So you--
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah,
I totally agree.
I think that's actually
part of the reason
I wrote this book, because
I talked to so many writers,
and they would find their
creative home with NaNoWriMo
in November and find
themselves as writers
and and they would have
full intention of taking--
going beyond NaNoWriMo
to write year round,
yet they'd have
problems about that.
Like in some ways,
I mean it does
feel like the whole world is
writing with you in November,
and throughout the
month of November,
#nanowrimo is trending.
And Anthony mentioned
the forums online,
we get like a million forums
posts the month of November.
So literally every writing topic
under the sun is talked about.
But I do think
it's like NaNoWriMo
is this great opportunity to
make your creativity a priority
during the month of November.
And I think as we
get older, creativity
has a way of falling lower
and lower on our list.
There's this great
quote from Picasso,
he says that every
child is born an artist.
The challenge is how to
be an artist as an adult.
And I bet we all
feel about here.
And so I think--
but I think it's really
important to make creativity
a priority every
month, no matter if you
want to be a bestselling author,
or if you just like writing,
and so that's what
this book is all about.
The 50-- The 52 essays, not
a coincidence with the 52.
One per week.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Well,
it's interesting you
say this about making sure
that we stay creative,
but for some people, like, they
with more stories in their head
than they can put down
on page, and they just
need to carve out some time
to do it or give themselves
permission to do it.
Other people want to write,
but then they get there
and then there's that
page and they're like,
I just don't know what to write.
I don't know-- or I
know I want to write,
but I can't come up
with the right words.
So it's a-- when--
how do you spark
that creativity?
Like you've got the
desire, but sometimes
you just seem to run dry.
What do you do to
spark your creativity?
What are some techniques
that [INAUDIBLE]??
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
There are a lot of them.
I'm going to talk about one.
I'm going to read a little
bit in the book here.
One of the things that I
think holds people back
from being creative is there's
this notion of inspiration.
And I'll hear people say, well,
I don't write because I'm not--
or I wait for inspiration
to strike before I write.
And so here's a little
take on the inspiration
that I think might
help people write.
Inspiration is a funny thing.
It's powerful enough
to move mountains.
When it strikes it
carries an author
forward like the rushing
torrents of a flooded river.
And yet if you wait for
it, nothing happens.
The irony is that so much
is actually created--
mountains moved, sagas
written, grand murals painted--
by those who might not
even describe themselves
as particularly inspired.
Instead they show up every
day and put their hands
on the keyboard,
their pen to paper,
and they move their
stories forward bit
by bit, word by word,
perhaps not even recognizing
that inspiration is
striking in hundreds
of tiny microscopic ways as they
push through another sentence,
another page, another chapter.
I write when the
spirit moves me,
and the spirit moves me every
day, said William Faulkner.
No relation.
This is the princ--
oh I wish there was--
this is the
principal way writers
finish 50,000 thousand
words of a novel each year
during National Novel Writing
Month-- by showing up.
And it applies to being creative
the rest of the year as well.
Inspiration is
often characterized
as a thunderbolt, a
brilliant flash that
strikes from the
heavens, a eureka moment,
and that metaphor
certainly holds true,
because inspiration can be
a sudden igniting force--
random and illuminating
and otherworldly
and even a bit dangerous.
Yet I think of
inspiration-- at least
the big gob smacking
moments of inspiration--
as more like Bigfoot.
Sightings of Bigfoot are
rare, and he's so elusive
that he can't be captured
physically, or even truly
on film, so his very
existence is in question.
It's wonderful to
believe that he exists,
because it's nice to
think the world is
strange and beautiful enough
to spawn such a creature.
But if you go out into the
woods and look for Bigfoot,
you're not likely
to find him, just
as you can't force sweeping
gusts of inspiration
to appear on any given day.
The muse of Greek mythology--
that creature depicted
in a beautiful flowing
gown, playing a harp--
was invoked by authors to
sing stories into their ears,
but I'd like to
recast this muse.
The muse doesn't sing the
words of a story to you.
The muse is conjured
in the telling,
in overcoming those lulls that
strike with willpower, grit,
and as much caffeine
as it takes.
I see the muse as hundreds
of invisible sprites
that sleep in the whispery
spaces between each word.
These sprites are enlivned only
by the breath of a churning
imagination, by the stirrings
of a story moving forward.
Such a muse is
ineffable, so miniature
that she often goes
unnoticed, yet an author
must trust that the
responsibility for bringing
those story sprites
to life resides
in creating a spool of words
that spin onto the page.
A writer is either
compelled to write or not,
said Toni Morrison.
If I waited for inspiration,
I wouldn't really be a writer.
The urge to wait
for inspiration has
killed many a wonderful story.
And I am going to end with
the Toni Morrison quote
there because Toni Morrison--
I don't know if you
know this story--
but when she wrote
her first novel,
she was a single working
mom in New York City.
And she worked all
day like us, busy job.
Came home, took care of
her kids, got them to bed.
And she had about 15 minutes
of the day left to her.
But she used that 15 minutes--
not her prime creative time,
not when her mind is like
super fresh and imaginative--
but in those 15 minutes she
wrote every day, and that--
she built a novel
by tiny increments.
And so I feel like this is a
lesson for us all about what
you can build just
through a daily practice.
And if she'd been
waiting for inspiration,
she'd still be waiting
to write that novel.
And she's moved on past that.
So I really do think, like--
and this is why,
and Anthony, I will
get to this, why, in
many ways, I don't
believe in writer's block.
I feel like we tell
ourselves we have a block,
but if you just sit down
and put words on the page,
you'll solve that block, because
other words like to follow.
ANTHONY FRANCIS:
Yeah, there's so
much I want to follow up there.
It's-- I think that lightning
bolt of inspiration--
and as a cognitive scientist,
we have this feeling that things
come into consciousness
all at once or not at all,
like you see something
or you don't.
Yet there's these
perceptual processes
that are churning in the
background all the time.
And inspiration is kind of like
perceiving your own idea space,
where it congeals, and
you're seeing this idea
that you've had.
But if you aren't
feeding your brain
with all these
thoughts and ideas
and trying to progress
step by step, it's like--
the muse can't set sail unless
you've already filled the ocean
with your tears of hard work.
GRANT FAULKNER: I love it.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Right.
So it's-- I think
it's really critical.
But then the Toni Morrison
quote, also it strikes me--
and I went to a
writer's workshop
with Walter John Williams
as one of the instructors,
and he did had us
do an exercise,
and he had us all get
together and write
for 30 minutes on whatever our
favorite writing implement was,
and at the end of that, he
asked us to do a word count.
And the word count for
people was everywhere
from 250 to 1,200, because
some people were very fast.
And the average was around--
I can't remember the
number, 300 or 500 words.
And he said, OK, if you
did that five days a week,
50 weeks a year, that's a novel.
That's a career.
And his point to us is that we
don't really have an excuse--
and this is a science
fiction workshop-- his point
that we don't really
have an excuse
not to be a writer
because it can be done,
at least in the writing
part, 30 minutes a day.
Maybe not the editing.
But--
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah
ANTHONY FRANCIS: But if you
have the text, you can edit it.
If you don't, you can't.
And then that goes
back to that--
so let's talk a
little bit about--
I want to come back
to writer's block,
but let's talk a little
bit about creating
the practice of writing.
How-- a lot of people--
like even for me.
I have done NaNo forever,
I've written many novels,
and I still struggle to
maintain a practice where
I am writing at
the speed and rate
that I wanted to finish
my books before I die.
GRANT FAULKNER: We all have
too many books in us, I think.
We'll never get the books I
want to read read or written,
unfortunately.
I just wanted to go back a
little bit for the writer's
block, and to the story that
you did about the half an hour
a day.
When I mentioned a word
sprints during NaNoWriMo,
which is basically
giving people a prompt
and telling them to write
for five to 10 minutes.
And per what Anthony
said, in five minutes,
I've never encountered-- at
least people on a laptop--
people write at least 200 words.
Even, like, people who classify
themselves as non-writers.
Which I don't think exists.
Everyone's a writer.
But it's the same thing.
It's that idea that even
if it's a rough draft
and you write 200 words
a day or 300 words a day,
300 words a day is like
10,000 words a month.
That's 120,000 words a year.
That's a huge novel,
perhaps two novels.
And again, it might
be a rough draft.
But the point is,
like, for me, getting
the rough-- writing
the rough draft is
the hardest thing for me.
I hate rough drafts.
That's actually what
NaNoWriMo delivered me from.
It helped me get
through my rough drafts.
I called myself a precious
ponderous writer beforehand,
because I would sit and
make the first sentence
or the first paragraph of the
first chapter perfect before I
moved on, which was entirely
the wrong approach to writing
a novel, because
that first chapter is
likely going to get
cut in revision,
or rewritten anyway,
so the premise--
I feel like I didn't
describe this quite as
well as I should have earlier--
but it's getting
the rough draft out.
And the thing is, is like
that when we measure it,
so many people, the one obstacle
they put in front of themselves
in a rough draft is that their
words in their rough draft
don't match their
favorite authors words.
And in the end, what
we don't realize
is that our favorite
authors have written
these crappy rough drafts.
We just don't get to see them.
We only get to see
the drafts that
have been revised
maybe eight or 10 times
and edited it by a
professional editor.
So it's really about getting
the words on the page.
And then you can edit them.
And now I've forgotten the
great question you just asked me
because I was backtracking.
ANTHONY FRANCIS:
We'll come back to it.
I just-- about writer's block.
I've heard a number
of people say,
writer's block doesn't exist.
I mean, I can show you half a
dozen books that are out there.
This is "The
Writer's Block Myth".
Half a dozen books
and blog posts
where people say the same thing.
And that's-- I
struggle with that,
because I also have read
the cognitive science
on writer's block.
But then strangely,
I realized they
were saying the same thing.
So the resistance I
had is like, I know--
I instruct on writer's block.
I do workshops.
I have people that
I'm like, just
take a blank piece of paper
and just write blah blah blah.
Just write any
words you can think
of just to get it started.
And they are-- find themselves
unable to do even that.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
ANTHONY FRANCIS:
And then for me--
GRANT FAULKNER: Really?
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Oh yes.
GRANT FAULKNER:
No blah blah blah?
ANTHONY FRANCIS: They
won't-- they won't do it.
It's called writing
avoidance, sometimes.
Other times I was
writing an article,
I knew what I wanted to write.
I was, at least in my own mind,
an expert in the subject area.
I wanted to write the article,
I knew what I had to say next.
And I was so paralyzed, I
actually lay down on the floor
in a building in this very
campus staring at the ceiling,
going [FRUSTRATRED GROWL]
because I could not
force the words onto the page.
And this is after I've already
written 800,000 thousand words
in NaNo.
And so I'm like, ah, so
writer's block-- it's real.
Yet, most people, when
they have writer's block--
and this comes out
in all the studies--
is they're filled
with all these--
some people are
blocked emotionally,
but most of the time
it's from having rules.
It's from having a habit--
to wait for your muse,
to wait for inspiration.
Another big one
is editing, where
you become convinced that
you must write perfectly
on the page.
And that's-- that made me
think of what you're saying,
as far as that rough draft,
is, we talk a little bit about
your inner writer and
your inner editor.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
Yeah, in fact I
do have a chapter
here about the inner editor.
I'll read a little bit.
Does anyone know what
an inner editor is?
Do you have any guesses?
Hazards?
Elizabeth, you're laughing
at your inner editor here.
AUDIENCE: Big jerk.
GRANT FAULKNER: Big jerk.
I like that.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
inner critic.
GRANT FAULKNER: Inner critic.
Yeah.
That person who's saying--
I like the big jerk one,
because I do think sometimes
that inner editor is
saying, you're not a writer.
Why are you doing this?
Why are you being so
pretentious to think
that you can write a novel?
Or the inner critic
is more I think
what I was talking about
earlier, where I'll
write a sentence,
and it'll be like,
that's just a crappy,
banal sentence.
Your favorite writers can
write that much more eloquently
and lyrically.
But then inner editor
plays a big, role
in NaNoWriMo in
the sense that it's
all about banishing
the inner editor.
And that's probably--
the slide here
is the power of
writing with abandon.
And so it's about
saying, inner editor,
you can't be here this month.
That's a really easy
to say, hard to do,
because our inner editors
are powerful figures.
But we say that.
Like, banish your inner
editor for a month
and just write, and
write with abandon.
And part of the
premise of that is
that when you
write with abandon,
you are going to discover ideas
and take creative risks in ways
that you can't even imagine.
That's one of the reasons
I do NaNoWriMo every year.
I came to NaNoWriMop
as a writer before I
became executive director.
And getting that rough draft
out and exploring my ideas,
because the rough
draft in so many ways
is just an exploratory draft.
It's not meant to ossify into
the structure of your novel,
necessarily.
So I like-- I recently
heard this quote
by Barbara Kingsolver,
where, when
she starts writing a novel she,
starts a page in negative 100.
And so she's writing
those first 100 pages just
to kind of find her story.
And that's the way I
view my rough draft.
I'm just finding my story.
I think Anthony maybe has
his more structured going in,
and I mention that
just because everyone
has a different
approach to writing.
And that NaNoWriMo,
and that as creators,
we have to constantly
be experimenting
with our approach.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: I was
on a writing panel once,
and we went down the list, and
everyone described themselves
as being--
plotters versus [? pancers, ?]
people who were plotting ahead.
And we got to the last
person on the list,
who was Diana Gabaldon,
who wrote "Outlander".
She's like, well, I
don't want the audience
to be misled, because it seems
like we're like 3/4 of this one
type of person, but
the average statistics
are the opposite of this.
So everyone is different,
everyone is unique.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah,
and I think every year
I do something different.
I'm more of like what we
call in NaNoWriMo terms
a [? plancer, ?] I'm in
between a planner or plotter
and a [? pancer. ?] This is
kind of how I describe my life,
I never go too far
into any one camp.
So anyway.
It works for me, though,
to find that middle ground.
So this chapter is actually
about improvisational writing,
which NaNoWriMo largely is.
But I think it connects
with the inner editor
really well as well.
Your inner editor
has a sibling who
can be more dangerous
to your writing
than even the growling critiques
of your inner editor itself.
It tends to walk around the
rooms of your mind gazing
at all the imaginative ruckus
with a persnickety, arrogant
gaze.
It exudes an air
of judicious logic,
speaking in the grave
tones of seasoned caution.
He likes to stroll in just when
you get an idea that you're
about to pounce on like a
puppy pounces on a chew toy,
and it says, but wait.
But wait, this isn't logical.
But wait, that's unpleasant.
But wait, let's
just not go there.
I think of But Wait as
an enthusiastic drip,
the kind of person who
sits smugly in meetings
and never quite gets behind
an idea for whatever reason.
The killjoy who lacks that or
the wonderful reckless zeal
that brings ideas to life.
But Wait is a volcano
that will never erupt.
But Wait has never led to
great artistic or scientific
breakthroughs, although
it comes in handy
if you're an impulsive shopper.
But Wait is quite different than
his twin, But Wait, What If?,
a wonderfully stimulating
thought partner.
If your brain has fallen into
a rut of resistance, a storage
bin of hand-me-down ideas
and shopworn sensibilities,
it's necessary to
find ways to open up
to new sense-ravishing
possibilities.
If I'm feeling too many
but waits in my mind,
I try to embrace the
opposite force, the guiding
principle of improv, yes and.
It's simple, really.
Improv actors are
trained to trust
the impulsive force of an
idea and just say yes to it.
They accept whatever fellow
actors offer in a scene,
instead of stiff-arming the
action in the direction they
want it to go.
For example, when one actor
says it's so cold in here
you don't say, but wait, that's
not a good approach the scene,
or but wait I'm not cold.
You take the statement
and build on it.
Yes nudity brings on
the chills, you say.
Or something silly.
And then your acting partner--
oh, thank you for laughing.
And then your acting partner
embraces your statement
and builds on that.
When I'm writing,
I sometimes like
to think that there's an
entire writing team in my head,
tossing ideas back and forth,
a veritable comedy troupe.
But Wait hates scenes
like this, everyone
getting ideas,
loving their ideas,
putting their ideas into the
world, onto the page in such
a sloppy, gleeful way.
But Wait tries to
speak above the fray.
But once the naturally
boisterous writing team
in your brain gets going, But
Wait's cranky little voice just
isn't loud enough.
Improvisers take risks and
make mistakes by definition.
They let themselves fall into
the most foolish behavior,
allow themselves to speak
what's taboo, because that's
what leads them in
fresh directions
and helps them connect
with their audiences.
And so I just want to
say that part of that,
like, taking risks is what a
novel or any creative endeavor
is is really all
about, and accepting--
for novelists, you're really
accepting so much failure
in that first draft.
There's so much of it.
I have a slide, when we get
to the workshop portion,
but Karen Russell
the novelist says
that 90% of her rough
draft doesn't make it
into her final draft.
Almost every novelist I've
talked to that's the case.
And so the rough draft really
is a sandbox, a playground.
ANTHONY FRANCIS:
Yeah, absolutely.
Because it's a chance
for you to try ideas
and then later you may
find they may not work.
If you write slightly
out of order, like I do,
the pieces may not fit, but
until you've got all the pieces
down, you can't figure
out where you're going
to have to lay that highway.
Keith Johnstone has a
great book called "Impro",
which talks about
some of the stuff
that with improv
that your talk out.
And I find the ideas,
great, but when
I've been on the improv
stage, I often kind of
find myself freezing up.
And because I haven't
done improv enough.
And this is this
goes back to what
we were talking about, about
that blank page and writer's
block.
If you think about when
you start to write,
you have to know
why you're writing,
what you're writing about,
what words you want to choose.
You have to be familiar
with your tools,
whether it's a typewriter
or a laptop or a pen.
And we have this--
we have a limited
number of things
we can store in our heads,
and in our working memories--
seven plus or minus two is
the old cognitive science saw.
And that's not quite accurate,
but it's a first cut.
And when you have
all these skills
that you haven't practiced
competing with each other,
you can just get jammed.
And that's one of the theories
why the blank page writer's
block happens.
And the way around it
is to do what we do
and the rest of our lives,
is to practice enough
that all those skills go
into our subconscious, become
automatic, and then we can just
focus on what we want to write
and we can let
the muse take off.
So to do that,
you have to write.
It's like to do improv, you
have to not just read "Impro",
you have to go to improv.
So what are some strategies that
we can use to help us keep that
writing practice going even
when we feel like we can't?
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah, thank
you for mentioning practice,
because I do think this
is easier said than done.
Like the improvisation
metaphor, yeah.
If you do that every day,
like you did NaNoWriMo,
you would build those
muscles in your brain.
And it would become effortless
in some ways, I think.
So practice is really key.
One of the chapters I
really like in this book
to help people face
that blank page--
it's an exercise that
comes from Ray Bradbury.
When he first decided to
become a writer and a novelist,
he did this exercise where
he would write down 20 nouns.
And he'd do it
entirely randomly,
just from his subconscious.
And then he would write what he
called pensays, little thoughts
or little tiny essays
about each word,
and they would be like
100 words to 200 words.
And in that process of just the
random nouns and then putting
his thoughts to them, he came
up with some of his best stories
and novels.
I think "A Wicked
Thing This Way Comes",
that's how he came up
with the idea for that.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: "Something
Wicked This Way Comes".
GRANT FAULKNER: "Something
Wicked This Way Comes",
yeah, I always
stumble on that title,
but this is all this say that I
do think that writer's block is
often something
we tell ourselves,
and it becomes an excuse.
There's a mythology
built around it.
And I think that if you think
about what techniques will help
you get words on the page, like
whether it's Ray Bradbury's,
or a simple phrase,
like sometimes we
give just a phrase
as a writing prompt,
or use photographs that
you find on the internet.
Or some-- I've known
people who write letters
to their main character, or
have their character write
them letters to themselves.
There are a lot
of different ways
to get to do an end
run about whatever that
is that psychological block.
And then I still think once you
get those words on the page,
they create a momentum
that is mysterious.
And that's why like
when we do these word
sprints during NaNoWriMo,
oftentimes you'll
get the prompt, you won't have
a story that you're writing,
you'll just have to
write as many words
as you can in five minutes.
And it's always a-- it's just a
this huge mystery and surprise
how words just kind
of come pouring out,
and they sort of-- they
make this interesting sense.
And they lead to
a story, even when
you don't think
you have a story.
There's a story in there.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Yeah,
you can really sometimes
just start with something you
don't know where it's going,
and then suddenly it
becomes something.
And both of the novel series
I work on, there's a section--
I can point to you a section
which came out of just kind of,
I had ideas that I wanted
to write something,
but the section that
just wrote itself,
and then everything
else had came out
of that, that spark that
got into that world.
And then sometimes, as
I'm taking in that spark,
it's like, OK, do I
really want to do this?
And fortunately, because
I write you know slightly
over-the-top genre fiction,
it's really easy for me
to take the But
Wait guy and say,
every time I hear that,
I'm like, if I say, like,
oh wait, should I really do
this, the answer is oh yes,
that, do that.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
ANTHONY FRANCIS:
Sometimes it doesn't work,
but most of the time it's
best to follow that Impulse.
GRANT FAULKNER: And
you learn that impulse
to say, no but wait.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Mm-hmm.
GRANT FAULKNER:
Through writing, right?
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Right.
GRANT FAULKNER: And
through hearing that voice
and like, and then figuring
out, but that voice
isn't guiding you
to better stories.
But that's the practice part.
And it comes out of the
practice and the pushing things
through to a conclusion.
Sometimes where I'm
like, should I do this?
And I put like three or
four ideas into a story.
I think it was on
my second novel.
One of those story plots,
arcs, had to disappear.
But the other three were solid.
And it's like, the thing I
wasn't going to put in there
became the thing
that I had to do.
And so sometimes that writing,
you get it down there,
you're happy with
it that moment,
sometimes you're
happy about editing.
I would be happy if I finished
the series that I'm writing,
which is rather long.
But one of them the
moments that I really liked
was when I was at a convention
and someone came up to me
and said, I read
your book, and I
was delighted to find out that
your character is like me.
Because no one had
written that for her.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: And
so that, in a way,
even if I never
finish the series,
that moment of a
reader's delight,
was a real moment
of success for me.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: And
that's something else
you talked about in your book,
is like how we define success.
GRANT FAULKNER:
Yeah, I think one
of the questions I get
asked most frequently is,
how many people--
like, what do you do
with all these novels?
Sometimes at it's
most disparaging,
it's asked like that.
And so this year for
National Novel Writing Month,
we'll have possibly 350,000
people sign up to write novels,
and we have a consistent--
relatively consistent-- about
15% of them will finish.
So what is that?
That's about close
to 50,000 novels.
And so the question is--
when they say, what do you
do with all these novels,
the reason I call it
disparaging is that I think
behind that question,
people think
that every novel has to have
the goal of being published
or that every novel--
it's putting, it's making a
novel into a product, right?
Like, why do this if you're not
going to make money from it?
But NaNoWriMo exists in part--
I mean in large part--
to awaken people's
creativity, and to do--
to be creative for the
sake of being creative.
And I think of sometimes
like, if you started knitting,
and you told a friend that
you were starting to knit,
they wouldn't say,
oh, are you going
to open up a sweater shop?
Like they wouldn't take
it that goal, end goal.
And I think you could like
say, I'm taking guitar lessons,
and you wouldn't ask me, oh are
you going to form a rock band
and try to get top 40 hits?
I think you can play
the guitar and knit
and just enjoy it as
an activity itself.
And the same with writing.
And that's not to say that--
I mean, I have
goals of publishing,
and I welcome bestseller lists,
if they find their way to me.
But I also think that there's
a deeper gift in writing.
And that's what I
really like to observe.
And let me read--
this is the final
chapter of the book.
And maybe we should
take questions after--
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Yeah,
I was just thinking.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
In fact, I won't read--
you know what?
What if we take questions now?
I just noticed we
only have 20 minutes.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Yeah, so
15 minutes, actually, so--
GRANT FAULKNER: 15 minutes?
So why don't I skip the
reading, because I'd
love to answer your questions.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Yeah,
so we have a mic,
so if you'd like to--
GRANT FAULKNER: And I hear that
David will give anybody who
asks a question a free book.
And he has 20 books.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: So
you must enter to win.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Where's my book?
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Very meta.
AUDIENCE: I've been doing
NaNoWriMo for quite some time,
but I'm one of those people
you call a rebel who's
been doing kind of--
I did the same
novel over and over,
then I abandoned it to write
a bunch of short stories.
I have had some published
locally, which is kind of nice.
I put-- bundled a few together
and put them on Kindle.
But how do you feel about--
if-- I'm going to do NaNoWriMo
again, I'm wondering,
should I go back
to my old novel?
Or maybe I should
start a new one?
Or--
GRANT FAULKNER: So
this is a really--
it's tough for me every
year to decide what
I'm going to do in NaNoWriMo.
I've also been a rebel.
Sometimes I need to
revise one of those novels
I didn't quite get
to from years ago.
Time-- I can't
keep up with time.
But I mean, my short
answer is to write what
stories tend to attract you.
And sometimes they
attract you equally,
but write what you're
most passionate about.
So if you want to go back and
revise, like think about, like
am I going to be passionate
about that project?
Am I going to be
really energetic?
Do I want to wake up
and see it every day?
Because I think there's
something really
important about working
on something not just
to get it finished,
but to work about--
I don't think we
should abandon things
because they will get hard.
The finishing part is
difficult. But I would try
to identify what's calling you.
And I think that can be a
really mysterious question,
and sometimes you
can't decide it
and you just have
to choose a project.
AUDIENCE: I think that's
pretty good advice.
Thank you.
GRANT FAULKNER: Oh good.
Good.
ANTHONY FRANCIS:
Yeah, I usually you
know try to take the
next project in my queue
and push it forward to
conclusion, because I've
seen a number of people that
once you reach that concluding
point on a book,
it's like a almost
magical sense of
perspective on what you've
done that helps you
figure out where you're
going to go next with it.
But then I know a lot of other
writers that are just like,
they go right up to that moment.
And they're like,
what is calling to me?
And I know a very
prolific author.
She's written, like, many books.
And she has gotten 10,000
words into something and said,
this story isn't
speaking to me, and tries
to switch gears and just
write the other words
in some other project.
So you-- it's got to figure
out what works for you.
But NaNo is also a challenge.
So figure out how you can use
it to help challenge yourself
while everyone else is
doing the same thing.
Any the other questions?
GRANT FAULKNER:
Let's have some more.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks for this.
This is cool.
GRANT FAULKNER: Oh good.
AUDIENCE: I guess
this is actually
related to the last question.
I have a real problem
of writing a lot
to the point where I'm
like just about done,
and then being like, eh.
And it's not that I
would like to submit,
or even I'll submit it
and then it gets rejected,
and then I'm like, eh.
Like, do you have any advice
around doing that last 5%?
In terms of motivating
yourself, like something
that you are excited about, and
you're just like, kind of done
writing, and like--
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like NaNo
GRANT FAULKNER: Are these like
novels that you've written?
AUDIENCE: No, no like
short stories or essays.
Pretty short.
GRANT FAULKNER: So
you just want to like
think about how to finish them?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GRANT FAULKNER: You're the
type of marathon runner
who quits at the 23 mile mark
and goes for the Gatorade?
Or--
AUDIENCE: No.
No, I don't know, actually.
GRANT FAULKNER:
Sorry, I'm joking.
[LAUGHTER]
No, I think finishing--
it is super tough.
And the reason the reason
I was questioning my answer
previously there was that
sometimes if you choose
to write only what
you're passionate about,
you might be leaving projects
before you're finished.
So it really becomes
this question of,
do I want to-- what are my
goals with this project?
Do I really want to finish it?
If I want to finish
it, do I want
to revise it enough that I
can submit it for publication
or give it to a friend to read.
So I mean, in the end it's--
finishing really is
about your goals.
I mean, a lot of it is in the
chapter I didn't read there,
like, how do you define success?
And if you want to make
it to bestseller lists,
then you're going to have to
think about all those rounds
of revision and the willpower.
Because it does take willpower.
Writing a novel-- I
mean, and the reason
I brought up the marathon too--
writing a novel is a marathon.
NaNoWriMo is a marathon
unto itself for a month,
but then going beyond
that and revising.
It gets very tough.
And every writer has
those moments where you're
looking at it, the project, and
you're just full of self-doubt
or you're exhausted and you're
like, why am I doing this?
Does this even matter?
I mean, I spent 10
years on one novel
that I guess I "finished"
it in the sense that it's
gone through numerous drafts,
but I haven't finished it
in that it's solid enough for
me to publish or submit, really.
But I also have decided--
I don't know, maybe I
will return to this.
There's part of
me that's decided
it's just that it's just
necessary to leave it behind.
It's not-- and that isn't to
say it's not calling me anymore,
despite all that--
the wasted thousands
of hours I put into it.
But we'll see, So I think
there are all these,
like, crazy decision points in
making and finishing a novel.
But it's a gift when
you're finished with it.
It feels so good to have
seen it all the way through.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Those
hours weren't wasted.
GRANT FAULKNER:
They weren't wasted.
Yeah, you're right, I totally
went against my message points
there.
They weren't wasted because
I was learning from them.
And every novel is a new novel.
That's the thing.
Novelists-- it's always new.
They're always-- it's
always a new challenge
to carry off a novel,
no matter what it is.
So I hope that all those
missteps I took previously
are helping me now.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: And flip for
everything that I've published,
anything that I've
written that is more than,
I don't know, 3,000 or 5,000
words long, every single one
of those, there was some point
where I wanted to quit and say,
OK, this isn't calling
to me anymore, even when
I was close to the end.
So you're not alone, and
if it's calling to you,
you will reach a point
where you want to stop,
but if you're this
close, just go for it.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
I'll say one more
thing, and then I
want to hear the next two
questions, definitely.
Ray Bradbury said, to
become a good writer,
you have to write
several hundred
thousand throwaway words.
I've heard people say a million.
I don't know.
Anyway, the premise is,
you've got to practice a lot.
So keep writing.
How about you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Hey.
Thanks for being here.
I learned a lot--
GRANT FAULKNER: Great.
AUDIENCE: From this.
So I was surprised, one
of the things I learned
was what you said about
Toni Morrison, how she spent
15 minutes each
evening, and you gave
the example of, like, if you
took 30 minutes, five days
a week, 50 weeks a year, you
could have a novel if not two.
How do you, with those
little increments daily,
create a cohesive story?
I mean, in my mind, by the
time I started writing,
15 minutes have
passed and I'm just
kind of getting in the flow.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah,
well keep in the flow.
If you're in the flow
and have momentum,
keep going, definitely.
I mean, in terms of how you
stitch together a whole novel,
I mean, people have
a lot of different--
every novelist kind of has a
different approach, I think.
And I know back to the
planning-- some novelists
I know, they plan their
novel so meticulously
before they write it.
I mean, they have really
detailed outlines,
they have software that
helps them do a timeline.
They really get into
the thinking it through.
And that helps them write.
And that's great.
That doesn't help me right.
When I write an outline, I
feel like I get pigeonholed,
my story idea becomes rigid, I
have a hard time breaking out
of that.
So I feel like I'm writing
more towards the outline
and not enough
towards the story.
So I just need an idea of
where the story is going,
kind of its direction
or trajectory,
and then I write towards that.
And that's because I like
to write for the mysteries
of my characters and the story.
And I think that that
happens without an outline,
for me at least.
If you're writing in 15 minute
increments a day, though,
and if you haven't
outlined your novel,
I would say you like you could
trust that you're creating
a momentum with that every day.
And the reason I say--
the good thing about
doing that every day is
if you do that once
every two weeks,
you're not really
creating momentum.
But if you do it
every day, there's
something happening in your
brain, whereas like right now,
somewhere in your brain, you'll
be thinking about that story,
or when you go to sleep tonight.
And I think that is
like a valuable--
and that's again, the
premise of this book.
The reason there's 52 essays.
It's just-- keep being
creative year round,
and it will build
into something bigger.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
How do you balance brevity?
How do you trade off
between like a high level
of detail, more of a
sense of a real time flow,
versus getting more
quickly through the plot,
getting past boring
bits, et cetera?
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah, it's--
I'm sure every writer has a
different approach to this
as well.
But for me, like, at least
within the NaNoWriMo framework,
part of the making the perfect
sentence, which I think
you were alluding to, like I--
and that's great,
sometimes writing
the perfect sentence can give
me momentum to keep going.
And you can feel
your story better.
I at least personally
got too hung up
on creating the perfect
sentence before going on.
And so NaNoWriMo,
the reason I like it,
is because it is this--
like the point of every word
is progress and to see, like, to
reach that point in one draft.
And for me at
least, I need that.
It might be--
I mean, it it is for
me a way of exploring
like the plotline of
the story in a way
that I can't do it
with an outline.
So it gets to be that
kind of like struggle
with the inner
editor, I think, where
it's that practice, at least for
me, to banish the inner editor
and to favor progress.
I'm not sure if I'm
getting to your question.
Am I?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GRANT FAULKNER: OK, good.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm supposed to
know all this stuff already,
so I don't really have a--
GRANT FAULKNER: No writer
knows all the stuff.
AUDIENCE: So I'm going to
throw you a softball-- both you
guys, actually.
What is the thing that you are--
that you most look forward to
every year with National Novel
Writing Month?
Like, I always feel like
it's kind of like a festival
almost, right, and I love--
I look forward to it every year.
But what is the thing
about it that you're most
looking for to?
What is the thing about it
that you most struggle with
or that you anticipate you're
going to struggle with?
And then like, have you decided
what you're going to write?
GRANT FAULKNER: So, looking
forward to, most struggle with,
and what I'm going to write.
Can I let Anthony?
Anthony hasn't talked in
a while, can I let you go?
ANTHONY FRANCIS: OK.
What I'm looking
forward to is there's
this real tension
between the moment where
I submit my final word count
and go, oh, thank god I made it.
Because that has been
actually like on 11 o'clock
on last night from time,
and then there's an event
called the Night of
Writing Dangerously, which
is a big just
celebration of NaNo,
and that's a really
a really fun event.
What I struggle with most
is there's this point--
doesn't happen every time,
but my life gets in the way,
and I don't start right on time.
And then I end up like 5,000
or 10,000 words behind,
and I am behind, and I
reach this point where
I hit the 25,000 word mark and
I'm like five days or even 10
days behind.
And I'm like, oh my gosh
the month, is almost up.
And then I have to
go into this crunch.
And that's the
thing that I dread
and try to avoid by trying
to get started earlier.
And the project I'm working
on is called "BotNet".
It's the second book.
So I have an adult series about
Dakota Frost, a magical tattoo
artist, and she's adopted
and weretiger child
called Cinnamon Frost, and I'm
writing the second young adult
book for NaNo.
GRANT FAULKNER: I think the
thing I'm looking forward
to is, at least
most NaNo's, when
I'm starting a new
project, this kind
of gets into the
third answer here,
but the start of the novel.
Just-- there is
something, it's a gift
to have an idea for
a novel and then
to write the first words of it
and to get it out of the chute
and into the world.
It's just a kind of
magical feeling I think.
The biggest challenge actually
happens about like week two.
Like I follow the typical
trajectory of most NaNo
writers, where out of
the gate that first week,
you're just like, the
words are gushing,
you feel so good
about the story.
You have so much momentum.
But the second and third
weeks can be really grueling.
I call them the muddy
middle of NaNoWriMo,
where you're literally kind
of walking through a swamp.
And it's super
tough to keep going,
and per what Anthony was saying
about when you fall behind
on your word count,
it is inevitable
that in the month of
November, you will get sick,
you will have a big
project at work.
Something will happen.
There's just something
about the month of November
that it attacts these things.
And but the thing is is not
to let that getting behind
affect your writing.
Like, the premise
of our event is
like, we want people
to write, and we
want them to keep writing.
So if you can't
hit 50,000 words,
if you only hit 25,000
words go for that.
The main thing is to
get your novel going.
I have so many
people come up to me
and say, I only wrote 10,000
words during November.
Well, there's no
only to 10,000 words.
That's a lot of words to write.
And let me think-- your
third question was?
Oh, what am I writing?
AUDIENCE: Just,
have you decided?
You don't have to--
GRANT FAULKNER: Have I decided?
You know what?
I have not decided.
This is a crazy year.
I'm thinking about
going back to a novel I
started over the summer, and
I have 75,000 words on it.
I want to start something new,
but I also want to finish that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
GRANT FAULKNER: All right.
OK.
Only one more question?
We talked too much.
We're can do two.
We'll go really fast.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Arguably your whole talk
has been about this,
but in case you have
anything particular,
I used to try to write,
every once in a while I'd
find a story which
I'd do, and I would.
But mostly I'm a perfectionist,
I would just there.
I can't write anything
that isn't perfect.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I could
do that for hours.
So do you have anything
which would address that?
GRANT FAULKNER: About
the-- being-- writing--
you're really embracing--
AUDIENCE: And beyond that.
GRANT FAULKNER:
Your inner editor.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GRANT FAULKNER: You know what?
I would get really messy.
I would do the opposite
of your inclinations.
Like if you're a neat freak
kid, I would go out and just
jump in a mud puddle.
I have a chapter in this
book, actually, which is--
it's more about embracing
the absurd or the surreal,
but I think, like, sometimes--
or to be more playful.
Like, there is a kind of playful
spirit to kids finger painting
and getting messy too.
And so I think I think
I'd practice that.
I think I'd practice
being playful
and getting messy and then
just that general practice,
like, building that muscle of
banishing the inner editor.
And write with abandon.
I don't know if I
answered your question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Thanks.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Yeah
I'm on board with that.
I feel like getting playful
is probably the best
thing that you can do for that.
And the most analytical
writing instructors you find
will tell you you need to
put aside your inner editor
because you just you can't
edit it with the speed
that you can speak and create.
Editing is done consciously,
writing inspiration
comes from the flow
of your subconscious
and you need to just let it rip.
GRANT FAULKNER: I'll mention
one exercise Julia Cameron--
she's a kind of writing
guru, creative guru--
and she says that morning
papers is what she calls them?
You know about them?
ANTHONY FRANCIS:
Morning pages, yeah.
GRANT FAULKNER:
You just-- you just write
anything, two or three pages
or for 20 minutes.
I can't remember
how she defines it.
But that would help.
Do we have time for
one more question?
SPEAKER: One more.
GRANT FAULKNER: One more, OK.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I made it.
GRANT FAULKNER: Good.
AUDIENCE: I just was
really curious, like,
what you guys think
makes a great writer?
I mean, anyone can write,
but what makes you a great--
what makes you stand out?
And then secondly, what is
your favorite novel or book?
GRANT FAULKNER: Gosh
that first question.
Do you have a whole semester
we can explore that?
I mean, so I'll give
you a short definition.
And this is in
relation to all the,
like, how to write
great suspense,
how to rate a great plot,
how to write great dialogue.
There are hundreds of
books on that subject.
And they all matter,
like writing craft
does matter to
writing a good story.
But I think what matters more
than that is a story where
the author makes him or
herself vulnerable on the page
and really connects with
the reader heart to heart.
And so it's that heart
to heart connection
about a story that
you can relate to
and that really gives
you meaning in your life
that makes that novel great.
And it's great in
your mind, right?
That's all that matters.
It doesn't have to
be considered great
by, whatever, a whole panel
of judges or something.
So that's my short answer.
And then, let me see,
your second question was?
AUDIENCE: Favorite book.
GRANT FAULKNER: Oh,
my favorite book.
That is the single most
impossible question to answer.
I mean, I really do have
hundreds of favorite books,
and they're probably
all equivalent.
I just, strangely enough you
ask that, just in last Sunday's
"San Francisco Chronicle" in
their book review section,
I was asked to tell about my
most treasured book, which
is a book called
"Under the Volcano".
And the reason I had
to come up with one
for the sake of the
article, but it's
a treasured book in the sense of
like when I read it in my life
and what it meant during
that period of my life.
And it was "Under
the Volcano", which
is just one of the craziest
novels ever written, too.
It's really wonderful novel.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: So, oh.
Let's see.
So my-- I'm going to
steal someone else's--
I don't remember
who to attribute
this to-- that writers write,
good writers write about what
they love, great writers
make other people
love what they love.
And I think if you can move
people, you're a great writer,
and it all depends on what
genre or area you're aiming for
and there's different
criteria for that.
As for the best book, I could
easily list half a dozen,
from "Ulysses" to "Atlas
Shrugged" to "Ringworld".
The two that leap to
mind most are short
would be "Old Man and
the Sea" by Hemingway,
and long form would
be "American Gods"
by Neil Gaiman, or possibly
"Gravity's Rainbow" by Thomas
Pynchon.
GRANT FAULKNER: Mm-hmm.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: See, I got like
six in there instead of one.
GRANT FAULKNER: Yeah,
you covered some genres.
Cool.
Well thank you so
much for coming.
I think we have a writing
workshop now for 45 minutes.
And also I'm happy to sign--
I don't know if we have time
for me to sign books too?
Does that happen at the end
of the 45 minute workshop?
OK, cool.
Well Thank you so much.
These are great questions.
I appreciate you
guys coming out.
ANTHONY FRANCIS:
Thank you for coming.
GRANT FAULKNER:
Yeah, yeah, thank you
for your great questions.
Yeah.